hi everybody mad Luigi here and the Ring
City DLC is upon us there's a ton of
content so I'm going to be showing you a
couple of really awesome aspects and
features from the DLC that are pretty
easy to miss even hard to find I think
these are all pretty essential to really
making sure you get the full experience
that the Ring City offers so let's dive
into it be warned though that there will
be significant area and possibly story
spoilers number one is the ring city
riddle on a wall near the streets
bonfire there's a note that reads show
your humanity
everybody's got a review copy of the DLC
spent hours trying to figure this riddle
out some getting it some not the key
here is to recognize the oddly placed
white branches in the nearby swamp so
head over to the swamp anywhere in it
and use one of these white branches
you'll be transformed into a humanity
sprite and now all that's left is to
walk back to the wall and strut your new
stuff
a ladder will fall and if you get past
or run past the ring Knights and the Jew
Decatur drop down head to your right
you'll find the purging monument similar
to the Velka statue with one extra
feature that will come back to number
two the Dragon Slayer armor maybe it's
just me but exploring that swamp to the
adjudicator in it is a pretty stressful
task I know I was constantly on the
ropes running around trying not to get
hit by that or the deacon so I included
the Dragon Slayer armor in this list
because he's kind of tucked away in the
back of the swamp at the very far end of
the swamp you'll find the Dragon Slayer
armor revitalized and ready to fight it
has a crazy chase range so I ended up
fighting it when I didn't plan to is
going to chase me all the way back down
the swamp when I tried to run if you get
this thing a grid on you you might not
be able to get a grid all take out the
armor you'll be rewarded with you
guessed it the armor quite a nice set
that we didn't get in the base game that
I think a lot of people wanted so it's
really cool to see that we get it now
number three our NPC invasion as with
the previous if you're exploring well
enough you finding every nook and cranny
really making sure you don't leave any
stone unturned you'll find these too but
some of them are pretty out-of-the-way
so that's why I included them first up
we have seeker of the spurned or alva
from the base game it's a bit before the
streets bonfire on the main staircase
before the swamp
take the first bridge detour and head
left past a couple of ring Knights will
be the Seekers spawn he also drops the
wolf ring plus three when you kill
next we have Lido of the cut-set can be
found a bit from the streets bontyre go
past the staircase and up the tall
ladder to the left of it drop to your
right head up the path and he'll be in
the stone tower the moaning night
looking a little bit like a certain
someone from the base game that has a
big hammer and defends Irina is someone
you'll have to come across naturally but
he's a bit easier to be if you ignore
him until you make it through the area
and take him out when nearby the bonfire
he'll stick to his route and you can
shoot arrows at them from safety you get
lucky like me he'll just fall off you'll
have an easy fight finally we have Shira
who can be found in the land of ash
after the fee Leonora's rest bonfire
head to your right instead of straight
and she'll invade you in the run town
building you fine I searched for the dog
stricken reception number four we have
the main course mid ear the optional and
possibly hardest ball for the DLC that's
somewhat pretty hidden away no doubt you
would come across meteor on the bridge
but if you're like me you just both get
passing the first time so you didn't
want to lose your progress it looked
dangerous and if you have the option of
running past things and Dark Souls a lot
of times it's a good idea to take to get
to the boss version you're going to have
to take him out on the bridge hugging
close to his chest and using a high fire
resistant shield should make the fight a
pretty easy one there is an alcove near
the start of the bridge you can use too
but I found it not needed really the
only thing you need a Dodge is his
smashed attacks but those aren't too bad
take them out and send them into the
chasm below
to meet MIDI air in in boss arena find
the elevator that connects the ring to
inner wall bonfire to the green pigment
statue before the church this is a
shortcut you should find natural halfway
up the ride there will be a doorway walk
through that and head to the left a nice
statue that lacks a weapon is actually
an illusory wall head through and you'll
come across one of the gravitational
anomalies were so used to in the ring
city head down and you'll be in the
monsters then
number five a covenant once you take
down the deers you'll be able to join
the new covenant of the DLC Spears of
the church as part of the Covenant
they'll get summoned to defend the
church from other players trying to get
through you take the place of half-light
in the second ball site allowing for a
lot of fun as a PvP boss mix the
covenants prayer Center is right in
front of the church near the ring Knight
with a duel sword another aspect of this
is that you can repeatedly take part in
both sides of this covenant you can keep
fighting other players in the shoes of
either the sphere of the church or the
aggressor trying to get through the
church to reset the church after you
kill the boss or another person plane as
the boss head back over to the purging
monument now we're going to choose the
other option we talked about before
reinstate the king of degree this will
reset the church and allow you to keep
fighting the ball this is also not a bad
way to get souls so you do gain a pretty
good amount of souls through the net
process I honestly do wish there's
another way to keep resurrecting all the
other bosses in the game too since being
able to fight bosses over and over
without having to go into a new new game
would be fantastic but that's all I have
for essential but miserable parts of the
DLC stay and look out for lower videos
and I do plan to do a lot of lore videos
on this DLC it is a lot of ambiguous
lore and I appreciate you watching peace
out